absolutely thanks very much okay i'll
make a brief opening statement
and this is about censorship suppression
and the 2020 election
sort of a deep dive when it comes to
twitter and facebook
about the platforms and the decisions
they make how they make them can we do
better
do we need to do better so the first
thing i want to talk about here
is uh health risk associated with uh
social media a 2018
p research center survey of nearly
uh 750 13 to 17 year olds found that
45 percent are online almost constantly
a 97 use social media platforms such as
youtube
facebook instagram or snapchat so
why are we having this hearing the
products that these two companies offer
people like and they use so
the bottom line is they've probably been
more successful than their wildest
dreams
and they're having to make decisions
that offend people
on the left and the right and what we're
trying to do
is look at section 230 and to see if it
needs to be modified or changed
because section 230 basically
allows social media platforms like
twitter
and facebook to pass on information
without legal liability if a newspaper
does something you don't like
you think they've slandered you in a
certain way you can sue them
if a news program does something that
you think is out of line
even as a politician with a high bar you
can sue them
these companies have liability
protection when it comes to the content
that their users um
engage in you can sue the person
who gave the tweet but you can't sue
twitter
who gave that person access to the world
in terms of what they said and we got to
find a way
to make sure that when twitter and
facebook make a decision about
what's reliable and what's not what to
keep up and what
what to take down that there's
transparency in the system
and i think section 230 has to be
changed
because we can't get there from here
without change
but in 2019 a study of more than 6 500
12 to 15 year olds in the u.s found that
those who spent more than
three hours a day using social media
might be
at heightened risk for mental health
problems
another study 12 000 13 to 16 year olds
in england found that using social media
more than three times a day
predicated poor mental health predicted
poor mental health and well-being in
teens
other studies also have observed links
between high levels of social media use
depression or anxiety the average
millennial checks their phone
157 times daily i don't know how members
of the senate i don't know where we fall
social media is
designed to sustain users attention with
a mix of good user interface
design and psychology creating an
addictive
mix for users it's called the slot
machine effect
a technique which usually utilizes a
pull to refresh
and scrolling mechanisms on news feeds
similar to a
slot machine the like button
a feature to provide social validation
through a positive feedback loop
by measuring and comparing the number of
likes a user's
content obtains gamifying
social interactions employing
gamification
to engage users and keep them coming
back
for example streaks is the one causing
the most
concern and using elongating red lines
to display the number of days since
two users interacted i guess what these
technologies do is try to keep us
engaged
the more we engage the technology the
more advertising benefit
to the company is that a good business
practice maybe so
does it create a health hazard over time
something to look at now the other
aspect of this debate
is are these companies newspapers or
their tv stations
do they have the power of
of media organizations that have
rules and regulations and the current
uh media platforms do not
there are rules about what a television
station can do
there are rules about what a newspaper
can do
and what i want to try to find out
is if you're not a newspaper at twitter
or
facebook then why do you have editorial
control
over the new york post
they decided and maybe for a good reason
i don't know
that the new york post edit
articles about hunter biden
needed to be flagged excluded from
distribution
are made hard to find that to me
seems like you're the ultimate editor
the editorial decision at the new york
post to run the story
was overridden by twitter
and facebook in different fashions
to prevent its dissemination
now if that's not making an editorial
decision
i don't know what would be it's one
thing
when we do it in our private lives uh
nikki haley made a post about her
concerns about mel in balloting
it was flagged as something
a claim this hasn't been legitimized
let me read it to you the next question
to ask
is why it a crime to raise doubts about
the holocaust
why should anyone who writes about such
doubts be imprisoned
while insulting the prophet is allowed
now that's the ayatollah uh
he's opining that raising doubts about
the holocaust
shouldn't be a crime and he is
openly called for the destruction of
israel his regime has
and his tweet was basically allowed to
flourish
here's what nikki haley said despite
what the media tells us
election fraud does happen and policies
like balloting harvesting
and mailing ballots to people who don't
request them makes it easier
makes that easier that needs to stop
this claim about election fraud is
disputed
well that's her opinion
she believes like i do that melon
balloting is
uh right for fraud if you can't verify
the signature and if we just send mail
ballots out to the world that are not
requested
and you don't have a signature
verification system that can be trusted
you have in fact led to harvesting a
balance
for nefarious purposes the question for
us as a country
at what point do the decisions by these
organizations cross a line
at what point do they have to assume
responsibility
that section 230 shields them from
and to the people are about to testify
i consider your products to have changed
the world
mostly for the good we're able to
interact among ourselves
we're able to talk to each other and
share life experiences
we're able to in real time communicate
to our neighbors and our friends
and those who oppose us what we think
with technology that just
makes it instantaneous and can
literally light up the world section 230
was developed
to allow these technologies to flourish
early on if you could sue twitter or
facebook for content
on a facebook posting or a tweet
and they were liable by for what
somebody else said or what they
felt or did then the company would have
probably never been in existence
the companies are trying to help us deal
with child pornography
we have the earn it act that to be to be
able to maintain
liability protections when it comes to
sexual exploitation of media sites
social media sites
or sexual predators this committee has
passed a bill saying
you can only maintain that liability
protection
if in fact you use best business
practices
and that's where i think we need to be
going my hope is that we change
section 230 to incentivize social media
platforms to come up with standards
that are transparent and opaque that
will allow us
to make judgments about their judgments
that the fact checkers be known
that the community standards who sets
them
what are their biases and give some
direction to these companies because
they have almost an impossible task
they're literally trying to engage in
telling us what's reliable and what's
not based on cable
news commentary or tweets from
politicians or average
citizens nobody in
a free society has ever had that
responsibility before
and the question is how do you
control that responsibility i don't want
the government
to take over the job of telling
america what tweets are legitimate and
what or not
i don't want the government deciding
what content to take up
and put down i think we're all in that
category
but when you have companies that have
the power of governments
have far more power than traditional
media
outlets some thing has to give
and i'm hoping in this hearing today
that we can find a baseline of agreement
that section 230 needs to be changed
that my bias would be to allow the
industry itself
to develop best business practices to
protect the sites against terrorism and
child exploitation and
other concerns that we look at the
business practices of these companies
through a health prism that some of
their practices need to be modified
because it can become addictive
you know we thought tobacco was a good
thing for a long time to the point that
we sent it to our soldiers in combat
the more we realized about the addictive
nature of tobacco the more we changed
our mind about
telling the public about the product so
whether or not we do that with social
media platforms that these platforms can
be addictive if
used too often i don't know if we need
to go there but i do know
that section 238 is it exists today
is got to give and i think there's
republican and democrat
concern about the power that's being
used by social media outlets
to tell us what we can see and what we
can't what's true and what's not
to the extent that section 230 in my
view has to be rewritten
so that's the purpose of this hearing is
to find a way forward to bring about
change
and when it comes to social media
platforms in session 230
change is going to come with that
senator blumenthal
thank you very very much uh mr chairman
and thank you for having this hearing
today
and i look forward to cooperating with
you not only in this hearing but in the
upcoming congress on our earn it bill
on other measures because you're
absolutely right
change must come to social media
the fact is we meet today in an
unprecedented and precarious moment in
american history
daily the president shocks our
conscience and shakes the very
foundations of our democracy using
a powerful megaphone social media
the president has used this megaphone to
spread vicious falsehoods
in an apparent attempt to overturn the
will of
voters every day he posts new threats
and conspiracy theories
about mail-in ballots and voting
machines
lies that contradict his own election
security
officials and his lawyers he uses
this megaphone potentially to block
a peaceful transition of power
now mr zuckerberg mr dorsey you have
built
terrifying tools of persuasion and
manipulation with power far exceeding
the robber barons of the last gilded age
you have profited hugely by strip mining
data
about our private lives and promoting
hate speech
and voter suppression you have an
immense civic
and moral responsibility to ensure these
instruments of influence
do not irreparably harm our country
i recognize the steps they're really
baby steps
that you've taken so far the destructive
incendiary misinformation is still
a scourge on both your platforms and on
others in fact google has been given a
pass from today's hearing
it's been rewarded by this committee for
its timidity
doing even less than you have done to
live up to its
responsibilities the recent actions you
have taken
in fact uh are simply
to check the truth of
what appears on platforms often it is
voter suppression and incendiary
malicious in misinformation and you've
tried to slow
it's in insidious spread that's not
censorship
that's moral and civic responsibility
now i believe and i hope the chairman
agrees that
a series of hearings on big tech is long
overdue
on antitrust issues on privacy concerns
and section i have urged
in fact a breakup of tech giants
because they've misused their bigness
and power breaking off
for example whatsapp and instagram
rigorous privacy protection because
consumers should have control
over their own data and indeed
section 230 reform meaningful reform
including even possible repeal in large
part
because their immunity is way too broad
and
victims of their arms deserve a day
in court but this hearing is certainly
not
the serious proceeding that we need it
may become a political sideshow a public
turret
and tethering my colleagues seem to want
to ignore
the foreign disinformation campaigns
intended to interfere in our democracy
and calls for murder of
fbi director ray and dr fauci
we what we're seeing here are fighting
words
and hate speech that
certainly deserve no
free expression protection
the fact is that the purpose of today's
hearing seems as much
to bully or browbeat you
mr zuckerberg and mr dorsey from
taking even more responsible action by
threatening cuts to section
230.
censorship is really a misnomer for this
hearing what you've done
is to label and to fact check
to avoid amplifying misinformation
and to
in effect impose those labels to
alert people that what they are
consuming
may misinform them and facebook took
down
ads for biden in michigan and the aclu
in colorado for mistaken information
about voting in short there was
action that affected both sides
i have fought for section
230 reform for 16 years from my time
as connecticut's attorney general when i
took on the scourge of
registered sex offenders grooming
children on facebook and myspace
with senator portman i have
led passage of the only successful
revision
so far to section 230 to stop enabling
sex
traffickers act known as cesta
and chairman graham and i have authored
the only bill to reform
section 230 that is actually moved out
of a committee
this section the earn it act pass this
committee
unanimously change is going to come
no question change is
on the way and i intend to bring
aggressive and targeted reform
to section 230 but i am not
nor should we be on this committee
interested
in being a member of the speech police
there are real harms and real victims
here and
in some ways this hearing is a betrayal
of
those real harms and the real victims of
them
those harms have been caused by big tech
because
you have failed your responsibility as
have
others in this industry
i want to see real reform that will
enable these abuses to be
reformed because your platforms have
embraced abuse
and weaponized child predators
violent white supremacists and human
traffickers and i've heard
heart-wrenching stories from the victims
you've
set back civil rights protections for
muslim americans who live in fear of
armed militias
organized by white by private
online groups uh
you have uh set back consumers and
competition
making that kind of anti-trust action
very very important the american public
deserves and demands real reform and
accountability
national consumer privacy rules
antitrust principles
that curb predatory power and reforms to
section 230
that shut that stop shutting
the courthouse door to victims i look
forward
to an opportunity for real change
and i think you can meet this moment
by putting your power and your money on
the right side
of history thanks mr chairman
well thank you a lot a lot to unpack
there
senator blumenthal's been great to work
with i'll continue to work with you uh
if we keep control of the committee and
senator grassley will be the chairman
next year and i would
encourage him to have the hearings that
senator blumenthal
referenced that this is a ongoing
conversation
to to get it right to the extent that we
can get it right
uh mr dorsey uh from twitter are you
with us mr dorsey
thank you the floor is yours
thank you to the members of the
judiciary committee for the opportunity
to speak with the american people
about twitter and your concerns around
censorship and suppression
of a specific news article and generally
what we saw in the 2020 u.s elections
conversation we were called here today
because of an enforcement decision
we made against the new york post based
on a policy we created in 2018
to prevent twitter from being used to
spread hacked materials
this resulted in us blocking people from
sharing a new request article
publicly or privately we made a quick
interpretation
using no other evidence that the
materials in the article were obtained
through hacking
and according to our policy we blocked
them from being spread
upon further consideration we admitted
this action was wrong
and corrected it within 24 hours we
informed the new york host of our air
and policy update and how to unlock
their account by deleting the original
violating tweet which freed them to
tweet the exact same content
and news article again they chose not to
instead insisting we reverse our
enforcement action
we did not have a practice around
retroactively overturning
prior enforcements this incident
demonstrated that we needed one
and so we created one we believe is fair
and appropriate
i hope this illustrates the rationale
behind our actions
and demonstrates our ability to take
feedback admit mistakes
and make changes all transparently to
the public
we acknowledge are still concerns around
how we moderate content
and specifically our use of section 230.
three weeks ago we proposed three
solutions to address the concerns raised
and they all focus on services that
decide to moderate
or remove content it could be expansions
to section 230
new legislative frameworks or a
commitment to industry-wide
self-regulation best practices requiring
one moderation process and practices to
be published
two a straightforward process to appeal
decisions
and three best efforts around
algorithmic choice
are suggestions to address the concerns
we all have going forward
and they're all achievable in short
order
it's critical as we consider these
solutions we optimize for new startups
and independent developers doing so
ensures a level playing field
that increases the probability of
competing ideas
to help solve problems going forward
we mustn't entrench the largest
companies any further
finally before i close i wanted to share
some reflections on what we saw
during the u.s presidential election we
focused on addressing attempts to
undermine civic integrity
providing informative context and
product changes to encourage
greater conversation we updated our
civic integrity policy to address
misleading
or disputed information that undermines
confidence in the election
causes voter intimidation or suppression
or confusion about how to vote
or misrepresents affiliation or election
outcomes
more than a year ago the public asked us
to offer additional contacts
to help make potentially misleading
information more apparent
we did exactly that applying labels to
over three hundred thousand tweets
from october 27th to november 11th
which represented about 2.2 percent of
all u.s election related tweets
we also changed how our product works in
order to help increase context
and encourage more thoughtful
consideration before tweets are shared
broadly
we're continuing to assess the impact of
these product changes
to inform our long-term roadmap thank
you for the time
i look forward to a productive
discussion focused on solutions
thank you mr torsi mr zuckerberg
thank you chairman graham ranking member
blumenthal and members of the committee
at last year's hearing last month's
hearing i spoke about the role
internet platforms play in supporting
democracy keeping people safe
and upholding fundamental values like
free expression
people have deeply held beliefs about
these issues and can reach very
different conclusions about the right
balance
we try to do what's best for our
community in the world acknowledging
that there are difficult trade-offs
i believe that some of these trade-offs
and decisions would be better made
through a democratic process and i look
forward to discussing that today
but first i want to update you on our
efforts during the election
at facebook we took our responsibility
to protect
the integrity of this election very
seriously in 2016
we began to face new kinds of threats
and after years of preparation
we were ready to defend against them
we've built sophisticated systems to
protect against election interference
that combine artificial intelligence
significant human review
and partnerships with the intelligence
community law enforcement and other tech
platforms
we've taken down more than 100 networks
of bad actors
who are trying to coordinate and
interfere globally we established a
network of independent fact checkers
that covers more than 60 languages we
made political advertising
more transparent on facebook than
anywhere else and including
tv radio and email and we introduced
new policies to combat voter suppression
and misinformation
still the pandemic created new
challenges how to handle misinformation
about covid and voting by mail
how to prepare people for the reality
the results would take time
and how to handle if someone prematurely
declared victory or refused to accept
the result
so in september we updated our policies
again to reflect these realities of
voting in 2020
and make sure that we were taking
precautions given these unique
circumstances
we worked with local election officials
to remove false claims about polling
conditions that might lead to voter
suppression
we partnered with reuters in the
national election pool
to provide reliable information about
results we attached voting information
to posts by candidates on both sides
and additional contexts to posts trying
to delegitimize the outcome
we lock down new political ads in the
week before the election to prevent
misleading claims from spreading
when they couldn't be rebutted we
strengthened our enforcement against
militias and conspiracy networks like q
and on
to prevent them from using our platforms
to organize violence or civil unrest
altogether i believe this was the
largest election integrity effort
by any private company in recent times
this is what people expect of us and i'm
glad that from what we've seen so far
our systems performed well but election
interference remains an ongoing threat
that will never fully be solved
so we continue to improve with each
election
but our integrity work is really only
half the story we also ran an
unprecedented civic engagement program
to encourage people to take part in our
democracy
we ran the largest voter information
campaign in history
140 million people visited our voting
information center
including more than 33 million on
election day alone
we estimate that we helped more than 4.5
million people register to vote
and helped states recruit a hundred
thousand poll workers
this was done in a transparent and
non-partisan way
as part of our ongoing commitment to
supporting the civic process
and on top of these efforts by facebook
my wife priscilla and i
personally donated 400 million dollars
to support election officials around the
country
and making sure that they had the
infrastructure they needed to enable
everyone to vote safely during this
pandemic
in my last testimony i said that people
would judge us by our performance during
this election
now i believe that the full story is not
only how we handle bad behavior on our
platforms
but also how we encourage civic
engagement more broadly
i'm proud of the work we've done to
support our democracy
and i look forward to discussing this i
also welcome the opportunity to discuss
internet regulation
i believe we are well overdue to update
the rules for the internet around
content
elections privacy and data portability
there are important questions here
including who should be responsible for
what people say online
for any system to work i believe there
needs to be a transparent process
that people feel they can trust this
will be difficult especially since our
country is so divided
but i believe it's the only way to
address these issues for the long term
the challenges that we face are deeper
than any one platform
they're about how we want to balance
basic social equities that we all care
about like free expression
public safety and privacy this is why i
believe we would benefit from clearer
guidance from elected officials
and i look forward to discussing this
today
well thank you both uh we'll have one
round and
seven minutes but i'll as always try to
be a little bit liberal with the time
because it's a very important topic
uh so let's just get right into it uh
mr dorsey you can go first then mr
zuckerberg
when you heard senator blumenthal's
opening statement
and mine what did you get from it
well i i think you pointed out that we
are
facing something that feels impossible
we
are we are required
to help increase the health of the
public conversation
while at the same time ensuring that as
many people as possible can participate
uh and in order to do so we need to make
policies
so that people feel safe and they feel
free to express themselves
to minimize threats of abuse of
harassment
of misleading information of organized
campaigns
to artificially amplify or influence
a particular conversation and
that policy creation that enforcement
is challenging but also it is
more or less opaque to the public and
that's where i think we have a gap
we have transparency around our policies
we do not have transparency around
how we operate content moderation the
rationale behind it
the reasoning and as we look forward we
have
more and more of our decisions of our
operations
moving to algorithms which are
have a difficult time explaining why
they make decisions
bringing transparency around those
decisions
and that is why we believe that we
should have more choice
in how these algorithms are applied to
our content
whether we use them at all so we can
turn them on or off
and have clarity around the outcomes
that they are projecting
and how they affect our experience thank
you uh mr zuckerberg very quickly please
what did you hear senator i heard that
there are
issues around content moderation uh as
well as other
areas and uh frankly i i'm optimistic
from the statements
that we may be able to move forward and
hopefully update some of the
the rules for the internet around these
areas i've been
encouraging and hoping that we would do
this for for a couple of years
and uh from your opening statements it
sounds like there may be now enough
common ground on views
uh that real progress can be made here
so from my point of view and the
question for us
is when it comes time to flag content as
being reliable or not reliable
um do either one of you believe that the
government should do that
is that a solution where the government
sets a regulatory scheme
that talks about what should be up and
what should should be down
i don't believe so i i think that would
be very challenging
okay do you agree with that mr
zuckerberg
senator for certain types of illegal
content i think it may be appropriate
for um for there to be clear rules
around that
but outside of uh clear harms
including things like child exploitation
um
in areas like that terrorism i i would
agree with your
your sentiment that that's not something
that that government should be deciding
on a piece of content by
piece of content basis so if we take the
government
out of the picture at least in
non-criminal areas
should we leave it up to the industry to
come up with best business practices
in terms of how to moderate content
i think that's best i think we need to
align around the problem that we're
trying to solve
and there are many solutions um to
solving those problems but
i think we also have to focus our
efforts on what is going to have the
greatest impact
and we believe that the greatest impact
is going to be found
in how we deal with algorithms how we
use those algorithms because they
are responsible for showing us what we
see
um or what we don't see and they need to
be
there needs to be more choice uh in in
their use
do you agree with that mr zuckerberg
um senator i think
that uh that there is a role
for regulation in the process uh even if
not defining on a piece of content by
piece of content basis
and one of the areas that i've advocated
for
is uh regulation around transparency
that goes beyond just uh
just about what the policies are and
what the process is
uh but also goes towards results you
know as an example of this
uh every quarter facebook releases a
community standards enforcement report
it's basically a transparency report
that breaks down
each category of harm uh
potentially harmful content that we
track you know ranging from terrorism to
child exploitation content to
incitement of violence to pornography to
intellectual property violations
yes if i may i don't mean to interrupt
but who sets those community standards
how are they set by the company
uh senator we have a policy team
that consults with a number of different
stakeholders and outside groups to make
sure that we're getting
feedback from a broad swath
is that publicly known senator i believe
so
and um our head of of content policy has
testified
uh publicly multiple times okay
so when it comes to fact checking would
you give us a list of the people you use
to fact check
senator yes uh we work with a number of
independent organizations that are
accredited by the the the pointer
institute
um and they include reuters the
associated press
um john's france press the united states
usa today fact check.org science
feedback
politifact check your facts lead stories
in the dispatch in the united states
okay i think it's important for the
public to know who sets community
standards
how they're set uh who does the fact
checking who you rely upon to do that
i think that would go a long way to
people having a better understanding of
the decisions you make
um mr zuckerberg
do you believe your product can be
addictive
uh senator i we certainly do not design
the product
uh in that way we designed the product
to be as useful
and meaningful and that's not my
question my question is there seems to
be an ample
body of growing medical evidence that
social media sites
have an addictive nature to them do you
agree with that
senator i don't think the research has
been conclusive but it is an
area that we care about and and study we
certainly do not want our
products to be addictive we want people
to use them because they are meaningful
and we we take steps to make sure that
this is the case so for example
um you know we don't give the team
that's running newsfeed
a goal around how much time people spend
on our products
uh which goes counter to a lot of the
the memes and
misinformation out there around how we
operate but
my goal is to help people connect and
find content and interactions that are
going to be meaningful to them on our
service and
our view is that if if that's what we
deliver over the long term
and people find the services useful then
they'll use them more
but i i don't think that companies
should be optimizing
to just encourage people to spend as
much time as possible on them
well time's about up have you seen the
movie social dilemma
senator i'm familiar with it okay uh
have you seen it mr dorsey
no i have not i would encourage both of
you to see it
so here's what i think we're going to do
on the committee over time i hope
is to ask the question more directly are
these
social media sites addictive do they
have a
public health component that needs to be
addressed for years we thought tobacco
was a great thing we found out tobacco
was not such a great thing
the medical science around these
websites are becoming very concerning to
me particularly among children
and that you can manipulate how many
times you watch
and you can set these uh media sites up
so that people will constantly
interact so to both of you i appreciate
uh coming for the committee we've got a
long way to go
i don't think the government needs to
regulate what we think or what we say
but we've got to up our game here and
i'll end with this last question
do both of you support change to 230
reform of section 230
senator i do mr dorsey
yes thank you senator blumenthal
thanks mr chairman uh
let me bring this down to very practical
terms
we're in the middle of another election
this election in georgia could determine
in fact which party controls the united
states senate
i'm concerned that both of
your companies are in fact backsliding
or
retrenching that you are
failing to take action against dangerous
disinformation
exactly the same kind of voter
suppression tactics
that existed in the last election and
that you are in
fact reducing content
modification the
fighting words and hate speech in the
last election could inflame violence
and send poll workers into hiding
discourage people from
coming to the polls we have to expect
the same kinds of malign tactics in fact
they are already visible and i'm going
to ask mr chairman that
these posts and tweets be entered into
the record
uh if there's no objection uh that are
aimed at
delegitimizing the election in january
my question to you is will you commit to
the same kind of
robust content modification
playbook in this coming election
including fact checking labeling
reducing the spread of misinformation
other steps even for politicians in
the runoff elections ahead
senator our policy is to have a similar
approach
in the upcoming georgia special
elections that we took during the
uh the general election mr dorsey
yes we do we and we intend to learn
from all of our experience with this
election uh and bring all that learning
going forward to make it more robust
during
the past election there was
rampant disinformation on social media
in spanish
speaking
sites uh repeating q anon
conspiracies and false claims of
election
rigging in my view you needed to get her
will you commit to taking
steps to improve content modification
for spanish-speaking communities before
the georgia runoff
senator this is something that we are we
were already uh working on and worked on
ahead of the general election
uh we have multiple fact checkers who
focus on
the spanish as a language and we made
sure that we translated our voter
information center
into spanish uh which we showed at the
top of um
of facebook and instagram to everyone
who uses those products
um in spanish in in the us those are
a couple of the steps that we've taken
and we're certainly committed to
focusing on this
yes we will in in partnership with
latinx
civil rights groups i'd like you to know
and perhaps you could submit to me
within one week what additional steps
you're going to take because historical
runoff is underway
and as i've indicated i've seen
a backsliding and retrenchment that
is very deeply troubling that have
enabled
the spread of this disinformation the
restarting of certain algorithms for
example
that promote or amplify misinformation
is very very troubling and i think
i want to know within a week what
additional steps
we're taking to enhance uh the
efforts to stop this kind of
amplification and spread
uh let me ask about facebook community
standards which ban
language that quote incites or
facilitates serious violence
as you know on november 5th steve bannon
in a facebook live video called for
beheadings
of dr fauci and fbi director ray
for not acting more favorably toward
president trump twitter banned bannon
for these remarks uh
you removed the video uh
mr zuckerberg but on thursday he
reportedly told facebook employees that
bannon
had not violated enough policies that
he should be banned from facebook my
question to you is
how many times has c bannon allowed the
call for the murder
of government officials before facebook
suspends his account senator
as you say the content in question did
violate our policies
and we took it down um
having a content violation does not
automatically mean your content your
your account gets taken down and the
number of strikes varies depending on
the amount
the the type of offense so if people are
posting terrorist content or child
exploitation content
then the first time uh that they do it
then we will
we will take down their account um for
other things it's it's multiple
um i'd be happy to follow up afterwards
we we try not to
um disclose down his account
sorry i didn't hear that will you commit
to taking down
that account steve bannon's account
senator
no it's that that's not what our
policies would suggest that we should do
um in this case
uh according to the internal records
that are
uh on record now leaked by nbc news fake
facebook has removed fact checks and
forgiven
infractions for conservative pages and
pundits such as
breibart donald trump jr eric trump and
gateway
pundit based on a fear of accusations
of bias has facebook avoided penalizing
or
fact checking conservative pages that
had violated its policies based on
concerns
of political bias and allegations of
bias
senator no we haven't done that
and i think that those reports
mischaracterize uh the actions that we
take i i'm not aware of any instance
where we have overturned a fact check
specifically
um and and certainly no action like that
would be taken
um for the reasons that that you're
saying
uh what we do sometimes is if
um is is applies some judgment on
um whether the repeat offender
uh policies
would would would render too harsh of a
penalty
um but that's different from overturning
a specific fact check
um and and is not done for the reasons
that you said
well i'm very concerned that in fact
facebook seems to have
a record of making accommodations and
caving
to conservative pressure and
the president has tried to use an
executive order on section 230
to again bully or browbeat
and exert pressure on you and
others in this industry uh they're
in effect working the refs and they're
winning
let me ask you about uh andy trust
issues
in 2013 facebook
bought onavo which is a virtual private
records network
uh that claimed to protect users privacy
in fact
lenovo's access to private information
about its users
provided facebook with unparalleled
ability to track
potential competition i want to know
uh whether facebook used data
from onavo when it decided to purchase
whatsapp in 2014.
senator i believe that data from o nava
was one of the
sources uh that the team looked at but
i i don't think it would have taken uh
using onavo to
understand that whatsapp was a great
product um
and i don't think that was determinative
in
my decision to pursue that well in fact
uh the house antitrust report says onavo
data was used to determine
whether whatsapp was quote killing
facebook messenger
end quote uh my time
has almost expired but uh let me just
say finally
that any trust action by the federal
trade commission is
long overdue i believe that
decisive action is necessary including
very likely breaking up facebook
as a remedy uh all options ought to be
on the table
including divestment of instagram and
whatsapp the ftc auto impose
strict conditions on how facebook uses
consumer data
and competes with rivals because the
abuse of competition must end
mr chairman i ask that three letters
from civil rights groups regarding
disinformation hate speech on
twitter facebook and youtube and also a
letter from a coalition of children's
protection advocates on the earn it
act and child sexual abuse material on
digital platforms be entered into the
record
thank you both for being here today
without objection senator cornyn
thank you mr chairman well
i'm glad to hear both of our witnesses
today say that section 230 that they are
open to reform
because i think it's fair to say the
internet has outgrown
section 230 and while we've made some
modifications when it comes to terrorism
and when it comes to child exploitation
i think
there's more to do but i
i think the question is going to be how
this regulation is going to come to pass
i know there's some including on this
committee who
suggests that maybe we ought to create a
private right of action
so that individuals can sue over
claims of violated rights on your
platforms
i think that's one form of regulation
it's called the litigate
regulation by litigation but it's
certainly not
my first choice and it's not optimal
um and i don't think
it's something we ought to be embracing
in the first instance
but i do think it's critical that each
of you and
your counterparts uh work with us to try
to come up with something that will
address the concerns and
the basic concern i have is it's hard to
know exactly
how to classify your business
model it's uh we have a provision in the
bill of rights protecting
freedom of the press but yet
here while we would never let the
government regulate
what the press writes or doesn't right
essentially we are
allowing private companies which are now
de facto public forums
to regulate that speech and i'm no more
comfortable delegating
those decisions to you that i am
delegating to you my vote
in the last or upcoming elections
you know louis brandeis famously said
that the solution for bad
speech is not less speech it's more
speech
and uh it seems to me like the practices
that you are
engaging in to tag remove and otherwise
censor speech on your platforms violates
that
that principle and i'd like to know why
that
shouldn't be a better approach by
allowing more speech rather than
censoring what is perceived as bad
speech
and then as i think i've discussed
with you mr zuckerberg the i think we're
all sort of struggling to come up with
what the appropriate analogy
here is to your business model um
we know as as the newspapers have become
less profitable and many of them gone
out of business there's been
consolidation in the news media
um there is a proliferation of cable tv
shows and
people being able to get uh information
through a variety of sources but
uh there's no uh walter cronkite or
the the big tv networks that with the
trusted uh
trusted anchor person who people have
confidence in who will
that they will shoot with them straight
and so i know it's a
it's a very difficult thing to manage
but i would just encourage both of you
not to wait for the lawsuits
we saw what happened to microsoft i
think bill gates said that was one of
his biggest mistakes failing to engage
with some of the anti-trust concerns
when it came to microsoft
and he learned that the hard way and i
think there is a better way for the
american people
and that's if we work on this together
mr zuckerberg i believe that that
facebook publishes on a quarterly basis
a report
of its actions in this area uh is that
correct
senator that's correct and could you
describe that for us and what motivated
you to
undertake that sort of transparency
yes senator i believe that in order for
people to trust
that we're doing a good job they have to
be able to see the results
and we have to be able to break down on
a
content on a kind of category by
category basis across all the different
categories of harm
whether it's terrorist content or child
exploitation or incitement of violence
or
pornography or intellectual property
violations
how much of the violating content is on
our platforms
and how effective our systems are at
removing it and
what we hold ourselves accountable
towards is
getting as high a percent of this
harmful content
down addressing it before real people
have to experience it and report it to
us themselves
so in categories where we do quite well
for example in fighting against
terrorist content our ai systems and
counter-terrorism teams are able to
remove
98 or 99 of the that harmful content
before anyone has to report a desk
um in other categories it's more
challenging and we're still making more
progress
but i think that as part of a regulatory
framework here it would be good if
every company had to uh
issue a transparency report outlining
what they're seeing on their platforms
and the results and effectiveness of
their content uh moderation system
so that way the people who are
responsible for holding all of us
accountable whether it's
journalists congress academics
could have an apples-to-apples
comparison about how all the different
companies are doing
and potentially as is part of a law
require that companies even maintain a
certain level of effectiveness
thank you mr dorsey when um
when twitter decided to take down the
story the new york post story on hunter
biden's laptop
did you do that under your terms of
service or did you do it under some
other
claim of authority we did it under our
terms of service
which um as you know everyone agrees to
when they sign up for twitter
and this was a policy around uh
distribution of
hacks materials we did not want twitter
to be a distribution point for hacked
materials
well you do realize that by taking down
that story you pro
you probably gave it more prominence and
more visibility than it ever would have
gotten had you
left it alone
we we realized that and we recognize it
as
a mistake that we made both in terms of
the intention of the of the policy and
also the enforcement action of
not allowing people to share it publicly
or privately which is why
we corrected it within 24 hours
and mr dorsey why isn't justice
brandeis's
formulation in whitney versus california
why shouldn't that
apply to the internet platforms like
yours in other words the
the cure for bad speech is not
censorship it's more speech
why wouldn't that principle apply in uh
to twitter i think it does apply
um all of our policies are focused on
encouraging more speech
what we saw and what the market told us
was that people would not put up with
abuse harassment
and misleading information that would
cause offline harm
and they would leave our service because
of it so
our intention is to create clear policy
clear enforcement
that enables people to feel that they
can express themselves
on our service and ultimately trust it
so it was a business decision it was a
business decision
like senator feinstein
thanks very much mr chairman um mr
dorsty in
recent hearings before the senate
commerce committee
you said i think that twitter has a
policy against misinformation
relating to civic integrity president
trump
and his allies have tweeted hundreds of
false claims about the 2020 election
the pres trump has falsely claimed
victory and alleged widespread
voter fraud so here's the question does
misinformation
about the results of an election and
voter fraud
relate to civic integrity why or why not
yes it does and and we we label those
tweets
um when the election has not been called
yet or multiple sources
have uh called it differently i'm sorry
i didn't understand that
did you say you have been able to tweet
no we we have labeled the tweets that
would indicate
a different um results in the election
called by multiple sources
i see at what point was that done
uh throughout the period october 20
october 11th
to up until today so
when the tweet was initially initially
came in
uh how long was it before you quote
updated it
we didn't update it we we put a label on
it pointing to
uh the broader conversation our goal is
to connect
people with more information around
what's happening with the election
and that was and and that occurred
anywhere from
five minutes uh to 30 minutes um
but as quickly as we as quickly as we
can thank you
is 30 minutes the maximum time
uh i don't know we can we can get you
that information
i'm uh in i'm interested in this
does misinformation about the results of
an election
and voter fraud relate to civic
integrity
why or why not
yes it does and we also label those
tweets
um that would uh um that would
indicate uh whether fraud was happening
and again we we connect those two larger
conversations
um on the platform so we want to provide
context here that is our goal
providing more context providing more
information
okay now a specific question and i'm not
sure
actually what the answer to this should
be but on november 7
president trump tweeted and i quote i
won this election by a lot
end quote obviously that's not true
president trump lost the election the
warning
label that twitter is applied to the
tweet says
and i quote official sources may not
have called the race
when this was tweeted end quote do you
believe
that label goes far enough to prevent
the tweets harms when the tweet is still
visible and not accurate
i do because it's not just the surface
level label
it points to a collection of
news articles of information and
conversation that gives you an expansion
on what's happening with the election
i guess you see my concerns are that
these tweets arouse
people and it seems to me that
uh the entity that runs this operation
ought to have an understanding that when
there is a major situation
uh that the tweets can play
a unique role in either reassuring or
stirring people up
um to unacceptable levels
could you comment on that
well i i agree in spirit
our policy is focused on
misleading information around the
election and the civic process
to provide greater context to provide
additive information
so that people can make decisions around
um
what's happening within the election and
that is three phases that's the run-up
to the election
that's election day um and also uh
the phase one right now post-election so
our policies
and enforcement are focused on providing
more information more context people in
those three phases
well let me give you a specific on
november 7
president trump tweeted this i won this
election
by a lot and quote that's obviously not
true
president trump lost the election the
warning label that twitter has applied
to the tweet says and i quote
official sources may not have called the
race
when this was tweeted end quote now
here's the question
does that label do enough to prevent the
tweets harms
when the tweet is still visible and is
not accurate
i believe it's really important that we
show people
a broader context and that is the
intention of the label
it is not just text
below a tweet it is a link to connect to
a much larger conversation
and use articles across the spectrum
well give me an example
of what would have to happen before
the situation would warrant a stronger
response
well we did have stronger responses um
during election day and
the week after where we did put an
interstitial
meaning that you had to click through to
see the content of the tweet
and it limited spread for any um
anything that went against our civic
integrity policy
including premature calls uh to the two
election results
well let me give you one more on this
november 12th
president trump tweeted a conspiracy
theory
the 2.7 million votes for him were
deleted
the warning label that twitter has
applied to that tweet
said quote this claim about election
fraud
is disputed now here's the question
and and i i think it is a tough issue do
you believe
this label does enough to prevent the
tweets harms
when the tweet is still visible it's a
highly emotional situation
but the tweet has no factual basis
but the tweet has a link uh to more
information
the more conversation and more context
uh
that informs the situation what's what's
happening
so i i do believe that connecting people
to the larger conversation giving them
more context
is the right path here but they have to
move
to solicit that contact right it's not
contained
as an addendum to the original tweet
the the label is an addendum to the
original tweet and if you tap on it or
click it
you will go to an expansion of the
information i see
um
can i ask a question mr zuckerberg is he
yes you may if you
want more if i'd be okay um mr
zuckerberg at the recent hearing before
the senate commerce committee
you said that facebook has a quote
policy in place that prevents any
candidate
end quote from quote trying to
de-legitimize the result of the election
end quote
but the hashtags steal the vote
and voter fraud garnered more than 300
000 interactions on your platform
in the hours after mr trump falsely
declared victory
so here's the question do you believe
facebook did enough
to prevent trump's efforts to
de-legitimize the election result
if so why have you reached that
conclusion
uh senator i believe that we have we've
taken
some very significant steps in this area
uh not just
the the adding additional context to
specific posts
and um making it so that when when
people search for
for different um hashtags we we show
additional information
but we also took the unprecedented step
of putting
the voter information center at the top
of facebook and instagram for everyone
in the us
that showed them reliable information
about the election including partnering
with organizations like reuters
and the national election pool to show
them uh accurate information about the
results of the election so
all taken together i think that
we really went quite far in terms of
helping to distribute
reliable and accurate information about
what was going on during this election
okay let me give you one more along this
line after president trump
falsely claimed that the election was
being stolen
a group called stop the steal was
started on facebook
it grew to more than three hundred
thousand users in less than a day
making it one of the fastest growing
groups i understand
in facebook history you shut the group
down
but substantial damage already had been
done
trump supporters some of them armed with
assault weapons
held stop the steel rallies outside
election offices in philadelphia
two armed supporters who had traveled
from virginia
were arrested on their way to the city's
vote counting center
here's the question and this is a tough
one what are your concerns
about the spread of misinformation no
matter how innocent it is
like or it is not innocent
like trump's claims about the election
that they may
incite violence
senator i'm i'm very worried about
about this especially any misinformation
or content that could incite violence um
and during such a volatile period like
this
one of our top priorities is making sure
that people don't use our platform
um to to organize any violence or civil
unrest
and that was the basis uh under which we
took down
that group uh because there were a a
number
of of members who were posting uh
potentially violent or encouraging
violent comments
that violated our policies we also have
broader policies in place
around trying to slow the spread of
misinformation more broadly even when
it's not going to lead to
some kind of violence or imminent harm
and that's why we've created
uh this independent fact-checking
program where we work with more than 80
partners around the world
um to help uh to help do do fact
checking because
people in our community have told us
they don't want to see misinformation
but they also don't want us to be
deciding what is true and false
uh so we uh so we've taken this step of
building this
program which i believe is more
sophisticated than uh what would anyone
else in our industry have
so i'm very focused on these issues well
i'm happy to hear that
because i'm really struck by it
that people armed with assault weapons
as a product of a tweet could rally
outside an election office and
i think it's really a serious issue
that needs to be considered and there
need to be
once you signal that
and people respond to it um
it has to be in some way abated
or some way pointed out
or restructured on the internet itself
uh now can you respond to that senator
feinstein
i'm sorry i hate that we're almost
double the time
could we i'm sorry that's right we're
going to have a vote come up and i
apologize uh
senator lee thank you mr chairman uh
first i'd like to note that
as far as the president's arguments
about the election and how they turned
out
inciting violence i'd like to point out
here that the only violence that i'm
aware of
has occurred in connection with antifa
antifa's
response to pro-trump peaceful
rally attenders so i i i don't quite
understand that maybe we'll have
a chance to dwell on that more in a
minute but first i want to talk a little
bit about federal law
existing federal law and what it
requires section five of the federal
trade commission act
prohibits uh businesses from engaging
in unfair or deceptive trade practices
compliance with
this particular law requires that there
be some consistency
between what a company represents as
their practices and their products and
and what
they actually are in other words you you
can't
sell one thing and provide another under
the guise
of providing something different than
what's being sold
both twitter and facebook represent
and have represented for years to their
users
their customers that they take a neutral
approach
to election content moderation
however as we've heard today and as we
will continue to hear today
and into the foreseeable future
there are instances in which your
platforms
are taking a very distinctively partisan
approach
and not a neutral one to election
related content moderation for example
just days before the election
twitter suspended the account
of mark morgan now mark morgan is the
commissioner
of the u.s customs and border protection
office and they they they suspended
commissioner morgan's
uh uh twitter account specifically for
a tweet celebrating the excess of the
u.s southern border wall
apparently commissioner morgan's tweet
his comments about the border wall
violated twitter
platform rules governing what it calls
hateful conduct
now i've read the offending post and the
offending post
from commissioner mark morgan reads as
follows
at cbp and the army corps of engineers
continue to build new wall every day
every mile
helps us stop gang members murderers
sexual predators
and drugs from entering our country
it's a fact walls work period close
quote mr dorsey
can you tell me in one sentence
what exactly is hateful about
commissioner
morgan's tweet that i just read well we
evaluated this tweet again
and we found that we were wrong there
was a mistake and it was due
to the fact that we had heightened
awareness uh around
uh government accounts during this time
so that was a mistake
we reverted thank you um
uh i i appreciate that we're gonna get
back to more of that in a minute and get
back to the fact that you know i
understand that makes mistakes happen
but uh what we're going to see today is
that mistakes happen
a whole lot more almost entirely on one
side of the political aisle rather than
the other
now commissioner morgan's statement in
that tweet as was
initially taken down is factual there's
nothing remotely
remotely hateful about it and yet it was
taken down
now on october 15th facebook relied on a
third party fact checkers assessment
uh to ban two advertisements from
facebook for quote partly false
information
now both of these advertisements were
factual in nature and they revealed
uh joe bidens and kamala harris's views
on late-term abortion joe biden has
stated that
he won't accept any restrictions on
abortion and senator harris's views
are such that she voted against
requiring care for a child born alive
during a botched abortion the very
next day the third party fact checker
issued a statement retracting the
assessment and retracting
it as erroneous however it
stunningly took facebook uh
almost two more weeks until october 29th
when voting had already started in many
jurisdictions
to lift the ban on these legitimate ads
ads that the fact checker had already
declared
a couple weeks earlier were erroneously
taken down so mr zuckerberg
why on earth did it take facebook two
weeks
to correct this error
senator i'm not familiar with the
details of
of uh us re-enabling that ad so i can
follow up with you after
um it's possible that this was
a just a mistake or or delay and
unfortunately when we handle
millions or billions of pieces of
content a day
um you know while we strive to to do as
well as possible and be as precise as
possible
um we will make some mistakes thank you
i appreciate your acknowledgement of the
fact there
are mistakes as i noted previously those
mistakes sure happen a whole lot more
on one side of the political spectrum
than the other now this is
understandable we're humans but it's
also uh
understandable why this might occur uh
maybe some of it has to do with your
employees
92.83 of facebook employees
who donated to federal candidates they
gave to democrats
at twitter it's even more stark than
that as if it could get much more stark
but 99.3 percent of twitter
employees who donated to federal
candidates gave to democrats
and so these mistakes uh they may be
mistakes but they're mistakes that
rhyme they may not repeat themselves but
they rhyme
and the consistent theme happens to be
republicans
conservatives and pro-life activists
now i'd like to ask both of you is there
a list of every user or every content
creator
who has been d platformed or had
uh their contents reach altered or have
had
some other adverse uh action taken
by either facebook or twitter altered is
there some
list that identifies each user for uh
which that has happened
uh mr zuckerberg let's hear from you
just
a yes or no question uh is does such a
list exist
senator i'm not aware of anything like
that existing
uh mr dorsey how about you
i'm exactly sure what you're asking um
but
we certainly simple question do you have
a list of people
your users or content creators who have
had some adverse action taken against
them either being
platformed or having their reach altered
or something because
of the content of their posts
well well certainly whenever we take an
action it's recorded somewhere
in a database but i'm not sure if that's
your intent no no
that's that's helpful so uh what i'm
hearing from both of you is that
well there may not be an actual list and
i'd like you both to check to see if
such a list exists
but even if there isn't there is a de
facto list because you have within your
databases
records of occasions when this has
occurred and so i'd like to ask both of
you
if such a list exists please please
send it to me i'd like to see it if such
a list does not exist
you certainly do have the data necessary
in order to generate
some and i i request as a member of this
committee that you generate
such a list and provide it to me thank
you very much mr chairman
senator graham the chairman of the
committee has stepped up momentarily
i've been directed to recess the hearing
uh momentarily so that we can go
and vote and then we will pick up back
here in just a few minutes
um i would like to uh as long as i
have the gavel momentarily i'm going to
ask one more question before i leave to
go vote and then we'll recess the
hearing
after this could i ask when we're coming
back i've
been waiting to ask questions for one
hour now yeah
uh we'll be coming back as soon as
senator graham returns he
left to vote in him just a moment ago
he'll be back
mr zuckerberg in september
facebook tagged an ad run by the
american principals project in michigan
that criticized joe biden and
criticized senator gary peters um
and the the the ad
was tagged because it was quote unquote
missing context
now the next day the ad was shut down
entirely
by facebook facebook relied on a
supposed fact check
from politifact which is a nice way for
you to avoid
taking accountability for the problem
except that the
facts check in question literally said
that the
ad quote makes quote predictions
we can't fact-check um
apparently this had to do with lacking
context so when did
lacking context become a new standard
for political ads i mean all political
ads all ads
in general but certainly all political
ads lack
context uh ben sasse just uh finished a
resounding
victory in nebraska and i haven't seen
his tv ads but i'm sure they're
brilliant this guy's made for television
he's uh with or without the beard
um and i'm sure his ads didn't say
ben sasse great senator but uh not that
great of a hockey player or
there's always context that is lacked
out that is lacking
uh left out in any advertisement
so uh what does that mean and have you
applied the missing context label
to any democratic ads a single one that
you can identify
senator i'm i'm not familiar with that
specific
standard but as a as kind of a
background on that
the fact-checking program the basis of
this is that we have heard
resoundingly from our community that
people do not want to see misinformation
and believe that it is a problem but
people also believe that they do not
want
facebook to be the arbiter of truth in
deciding everything that is true and
false and
uh for what it's worth i strongly agree
with that um and
and i do not think it is the right thing
for us to uh assume that role
so within those bounds uh we've tried to
create a
fact-checking program that works with
independent um
third parties who have been accredited
by the the pointer institute for for
journalism which i
um which i think is widely respected and
we we give those fact checkers the
latitude
to determine um whether ads
or other content on our service
is um is accurate and and if not we we
apply some demotions or we prevent them
from being run as ads
um i can follow up in more detail
afterwards
on on the specifics of of your questions
since i'm i'm not as familiar with them
right now i i would appreciate that very
much
if you'd be willing to do that because
it's it's not only inconsistent with
with logic and with what
the standards that apply in every other
advertising context that i'm
familiar with it's also inconsistent
with what
facebook itself does i did just to give
you some context for that while we're
talking about missing context
i recently posted something about the
election on facebook
and my facebook
post was almost immediately tagged
with the following quote election
officials say that voter fraud
which is historically rare has not
affected the outcome of in this election
they have confirmed that mail-in voting
was conducted in accordance with state
voting rules
close quote now i find this a little
disturbing
towns tag to me sounds a whole lot more
like state-run
media announcing the party line
rather than a a neutral company as it
purports to be running
an open online forum this kind of
editorializing insulates
people from the truth and it insinuates
that anyone concerned about voter fraud
must be crazy it also states it as if it
were
an irrefutable neutral objective fact
now maybe these kinds of concerns are
out of the mainstream
in palo alto but
they're not out of the mainstream with
the rest of america i i
i i have to reiterate i i hope this kind
of manipulation
wasn't intentional but it's getting
harder and harder for me to accept the
premise that
it could be anything but intentional
and if it was intentional it's yet more
evidence that facebook's
actions surrounding this election are
incongruent
with the promises that you've made to
your own users
and that's a problem consistent with the
directions have been given by chairman
graham we're now going to recess i
predict we'll be in recess for
no more than uh 10 or 15 minutes until
chairman graham
returns we stand in recess
[Music]
um
which is basically hockey i